ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนผู้เรียนวันนี้วันอะไร
คะวันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะ
ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤษภาคมค่ะ
ค่ะปีพตอะไรคะปีพตต
2565 ค่ะคลี
ปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ
2000  22 ค่ะ
ค่ะตอนนี้เวลาจะมากี่โมงคะครูเรียม by
02:56 นาทีแล้วค่ะผู้หญิง
บ่าย2โมงทุเรียนกินข้าวหรือยังคะ
ยังไม่กินเลยค่ะผู้หญิงกินข้าวยัง
กินข้าวแล้วค่ะอิ่มแล้วคู่เรียงยังไม่ได้
กินไม่หิวหรอคะ
ไม่หิวค่ะแค่กิน
แอปเปิ้ลกินกล้วยก็โอเค
แบบทุกวันใช่ไหมทุกวันเนี่ยเราต้องกิน
ข้าวคู่เรียมเคยลืมกินข้าวไหมกับอาจารย์
จะทำงานทำงานทำงานนานแล้วก็ไม่ได้ดูเวลา
ทำงานทำงานแล้วก็ลืมไปเลยว่าต้องกินบ่เคย
ไหมคะเคยค่ะผู้หญิงทำงานทำงานตั้งแต่
ประมาณ
8:00 น
8:00 นแล้วก็ทำงานทำงานทำงานจนถึง 02:00
นไม่
ได้กินข้าวเลย
ใช่ลืม
คิดว่าอันนี้นอกจากลืมกินข้าวแล้วก็ลืม
เวลาด้วยใช่ไหมทำงานนานจนลืมว่าเอ๊ยเวลา
กี่โมงแล้วใช่ค่ะผู้หญิงมารู้สึกหิวหิวก็
ดู
บ่ายสองแล้ว
งูยังไม่ได้กินข้าวเลยๆแล้วผู้หญิงมีลืม
กินข้าวไหมคะ
ไม่นะ
แต่ปกติไม่ลืมกินข้าวเพราะว่าหิวไงพอเรา
หิวใช่ไหมถ้าเกิดเราไม่ได้กินข้าวเนี่ย
เราก็จะหิวท้องก็จะร้องกับจ๊อกๆก็เลยไม่
ได้ลืมกินข้าวแต่ว่า
ทำงานแล้วก็ลืมเวลาเนี่ยก็เคยมันทีก็นั่ง
หาตอนกลางคืนใช่ไหมต้องนอนแต่ว่านั่งคิด
มันคิด topic ได้ก็นั่งหาทองปีกหาต้องปิด
แล้วก็แบบเองเข้ามาง่วงจังเลยแล้วก็ดูอีก
ทีนึงหนูกินเลี้ยงคืนแล้วเพียงคืนพวกผู้
หญิงจะนอนประมาณ 22:00 นไง 4 ทุ่มก็จะนอน
แล้ว
รู้ผู้หญิงลืมดูเวลาใช่ไหมคะ
อายทำงานจนลืมเวลาเลยแล้วก็ปกติเนี่ยมี
ผู้หญิงก็เป็นคนขี้ลืมนะคะครูเรียมที่บับ
ขี้ลืมกูว่า
ผู้หญิงต้องลืมลืมบ่อยๆไปๆ
ใช่ค่ะอ่ะเพราะผู้หญิงไม่ได้เอามาวางไว้
คือมันจะมีอย่างนึงที่กูหญิงลืมบ่อยมากๆ
ก็คือกรรไกรตัดเล็บ
น่าจะไม่ไม่ไม่ได้อยู่ตรงนี้ก็ไม่รู้อยู่
ที่ไหนเนี่ยคือแบบตัดเล็บใช่ไหมเล็บเนี่ย
เล็บหรออ่าเล็บเราเนี่ยมันจะยาวก็แบบไม่
ได้ชอบให้ไอ้เล็กมันยาวมากๆว่าเวลาเล็บ
ยาวมากๆนะที่เราสระผมแรงๆหรือว่าใส่เสื้อ
ใส่เสื้อใส่กางเกงแล้วรูดซิปบางครั้ง
เนี่ยเล็บมันไปโดนกับซิปอย่างแน่นอนนัก
เรียนเราเป็นยังไงบ้างแม่กระเป๋า
ซิปขอให้มีสิวเล็บที่อ่ะอ่ะหนูใช่เนี่ย
สิบวันที่เรียบร้อยไปโดนไงแล้วมันฉี่ผู้
หญิงก็เลยแบบจะตัดเล็บสมัยอาบน้ำเสร็จก็
จะตัดเล็บแล้วทุกครั้งเนี่ยก็จะแบบกว้าง
กันก็ได้ตัดเล็บไว้ที่ไหนผู้หญิงอายุเล็บ
หาไม่เจอ
คิดว่าน่าจะเดือนละครั้งหนึ่งเดือนก็ตัด
เล็บ 1 ครั้ง
ก็จะจำนะสมมติเปล่าวันนี้ใช่ไหมคะวันนี้
เนี่ยจะตัดเล็บก็หากรรไกรตัดเล็บหาไม่เจอ
เพราะว่าไม่รู้เอาไปวางไว้ที่ไหนอ่าแล้ว
ก็หาพอเจอปุ๊บกะตัดตัดตัดเสร็จก็คิดต้อง
วางไว้ที่นี่วางไว้ที่นี่คราวหน้าจะได้
ไม่ลืม
แต่เพราะอีก 1 ดูก็จะตัดเล็บให้เข้าใจกัน
รีบอยู่ที่ไหน
โอ้โหเหมือน
เหมือนบอกว่าอันนี้ก็ไม่ดีเนาะจริงๆเรา
ต้องวางของให้เขาเรียกอะไรอ่ะวาฬที่เดิม
ชายกรรไกรตัดเล็บอยู่ในห้องน้ำก็ต้องไว้
ที่ห้องน้ำเหมือนเดิมและพรุ่งนี้นะหยิบ
จากห้องน้ำวางบนโต๊ะทำงานเสร็จวางที่
เตียงนอนก็เลยจ่อมไม่ได้นะลืมเป็นคนขี้
ลืมค่ะครูเรียมราคาครูเรียมเป็นคนขี้ลืม
ไหม
คิดว่าเป็นคนขี้ลืมเหมือนกันนะคะเหมือน
กับผู้หญิงเลยของเรียงจะเป็น
กุญแจ
เดี๋ยวหาก่อนกุญแจอะไรอย่างครูหญิงเนี่ย
ผู้อย่าลืมกุญแจบ้านนะครูเรียมอันนี้เป็น
กุญแจบ้านนะคะคุณแจห้องไม่ลืมเพราะว่า
เวลาออกจากห้องเนี่ยถ้าผู้หญิงลืมกุญแจก็
ล็อคห้องไม่ได้
กุญแจห้องกับคีย์การ์ดเนี่ยไม่ลืมหรือยัง
ถ้าเกิดแต่ครูเรียม
อยู่บ้านคนเดียวก็จะไม่ลืมไม่ลืมกุญแจ
แต่ถ้าเกิดพ่อพ่อกับแม่อยู่บ้านเตรียมก็
จะขับรถออกมาแล้วก็ลืมกุญแจ
เพราะว่าไม่ต้องไม่ต้องล็อคไม่ต้องล็อคก็
เลยมั้ง
ส่วนใหญ่ครูเรียมเจอลืมกุญแจไส้ไหมลืม
กุญแจแบบกุญแจบ้างใช่แล้ว
บางทีก็ลืมโทรศัพท์นะผู้หญิง
คือแบบน่าจะเป็นของที่ของที่เราลืมบ่อยๆ
ไหม
ใช่สำหรับเรียนลืมบ่อยมากๆเลยโทรศัพท์
ทุเรียนลืมลืมยังไงคะคือครูยังออกจากบ้าน
แล้วก็ลืมโทรศัพท์ไว้ที่บ้านใช่
หาที่บ้านก็ดูทีวีเราก็ออกนอกบ้านมาก็ขับ
มอเตอร์ไซค์ออกมาขับรถยนต์ออกมาเลยแล้วก็
เวลาออกไปข้างนอกแล้ว
คนค้นในกระเป๋า
โทรศัพท์อยู่ไหนโทรศัพท์อยู่ไหน
ใช่
ก็เลยต้องขับรถกลับบ้านมาเอาไหม
บางครั้งค่ะบางครั้งกลับมาเอาเพราะว่าคิด
ว่าเดี๋ยวมีคนโทรเข้ามาอือ
ถ้า
จ่ายบางคนผู้หญิงแล้วไม่
ไม่ค่อยไม่ค่อยลืมโทรศัพท์นะเกือบเคย 1
ครั้งที่ลืมโทรศัพท์เพราะว่าไปทำงานช่วย
ไปทำงานแล้วก็เบาะออกจากบ้านขึ้นรถไฟฟ้า
BTS คือแบบพอจะขึ้นรถไฟฟ้าเนี่ยปกติ
ก็จะคือเหมือนเมื่อก่อนแล้วก็จะเอา
โทรศัพย์เนาะฟังเพลงบนรถไฟฟ้า
หรือว่าเนี้ยก็จะหยิบโทรศัพท์แล้วก็แบบ
เหมือนกูเรียนมาหาหยิบกระเป๋ามาแล้วก็หา
โทรศัพท์อยู่ไหนก็เลยคิดอ่ะจังหวัดนี้ลืม
โทรศัพท์แต่กูหญิงเนี่ยไม่ก็ก็
เอาไอ้ที่บ้านไม่เป็นไรไปออฟฟิศฮะโอเค
บอกคนที่ออฟฟิศไปกดก็ไม่เป็นไรนะทุกคนโทร
มาครูหญิงก็ไม่ได้รับอยู่แล้วเพราะว่า
โทรศัพท์อยู่ที่บ้านแต่ว่ามันก็จะมีบางคน
แบบเอาโทรศัพท์ไปออฟฟิศใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็ทุก
คนเนี่ยคือผู้หญิงคิดว่าทุกคนจะติด
โทรศัพท์มากๆโทรศัพท์จะอยู่กับตัวเราตลอด
เวลา
แต่บางคนเนี่ยจะลืมแบบว่าเอ๋วางโทรศัพท์
ไว้ที่ไหนในออฟฟิศหรือว่าวางกับบางทีเล่น
โทรศัพท์โต๊ะวางเอาไว้วางไว้แล้วก็รู้ไป
เลยเฮ้ยคุยหญิงเคยลืมโทรศัพท์มันก็ไม่ใช่
ลืมเนาะมันหายมากกว่าเราไม่ใช่หรือไม่ใช่
เร่ง
ผู้ใช้อันแมนโทรศัพท์มันลงก่อนไงเปล่า
แล้วมันค่อยหาย
ใช่ค่ะก็เหมือนแบบป๊อใช่เคยลืม
iPod
โง่ปิ๊กคือตัวใหม่นั้นน่ะมันมี iPod ใช่
ไหม iPod มันจะคล้ายๆกับโทรศัพท์ iPhone
น่ะคุณจะมี iPod ที่ที่มันจะแบบประมาณ
เนี้ยไม่ได้ใหญ่ขนาดนี้นะคะนักเรียนแต่
ไม่ใช่ iPod เล็กๆนะนี่คือของผู้หญิงจะ
เป็น iPod ที่ชายค่ะเคยลืม iPod ไว้ที่
ห้องน้ำที่ออฟฟิศ
กลับบ้านเราก็เหมือนกับเวลาเราเข้าห้อง
น้ำอ่ะแล้วแบบสมุดเมื่อก่อนไม่มีมันไม่มี
หูฟังที่เป็นบลูทูธผู้หญิงไม่มีมันก็จะมี
หูฟังหูฟังแล้วก็มีสายแบบยาวๆและเวลาเรา
เข้าห้องน้ำเนี่ยมันไม่โอเคคุยก็ถอดแล้ว
ก็วางไว้ข้างหลังข้างหลังห้องน้ำมันจะมี
ฉันใช่ไหมคะก็วางเอาไว้อ่าอ่ะมีห้องน้ำ
แล้วเสร็จกระเป๋าอยู่ข้างหน้านั้นประตู
เนี่ยประตูห้องน้ำมันจะมีเหมือนเหมือน
ตะขอยังไงอ่ะให้เราแขวนกระเป๋าแล้วก็เห็น
กระเป๋าแล้วก็หยิบกระเป๋าแล้วก็กลับบ้าน
แล้วต้อง
ลืมที่ยังไม่ถึง
ใช่จำไม่ได้คิดว่ายังไม่ถึงบ้านกูวิ่ง
ขึ้นมาขึ้นลิฟท์มาแล้วก็แบบคือมันจะมี
ห้องน้ำแค่ตี๋ห้องหนึ่งสองสามสี่สวยเราก็
จ่อมได้ว่าเราเข้าห้องไหนแล้วกูวิ่งไป
แล้วก็แบบไม่มีไม่มี iPod แล้วยี่ห้อแล้ว
เราก็ถามแม่บ้านไม่มีค่ะแล้วก็ถามแม่บ้าน
คนที่ทำความสะอาดที่ออฟฟิศสมัยเราก็รู้
จักกันก็ถามเขาก็พาไปเหมือนกับเป็น
information เพราะว่าเมื่อก่อนโรงเรียน
จะมี information ภาษาอังกฤษ information
ภาษาไทยภาษาไทยเนี่ยปิดแล้วขอเกาะไปถาม
ที่ภาษาอังกฤษเขาก็บอกว่าไม่มีใครเอาพ่อ
เขาจะมีเหมือนคล้ายๆเป็น Lost  and  found
หรอที่รักเวลามีคนลืมของอย่างนี้ค่ะแม่
บ้านเนี่ยเขาก็จะเก็บมาแล้วก็ฝากไว้ที่
information หรือว่าเด็กๆนักเรียนเรียน
ภาษาอังกฤษเขาก็จะเก็บมาแล้วก็ให้ที่
information ผู้หญิงก็ไปถามแม่บ้านก็บอก
มาๆๆไปถาม information มีคนเจอหรือเปล่า
ต่อไปถามไม่เหลือเธอไหมฮะอ้อไม่มีหรอ
ไม่มีกูครูเรียมไม่เจอเลยแล้วคุยเท่านั้น
ประมาณ iPad  iPod น่าจะประมาณแบบจำชื่อ
ว่าหูทันมั้งตอนนั้นน่ะกูขอฝากนักเรียน
ซื้อ
7  8 ปีที่แล้วมั้ย 10 ปิติ 10 ปีที่
แล้วประมาณ 2012 ปี 2013
ทรายแพ้หรือฝากนักเรียนซื้อใช่ฝากนัก
เรียนซื้อจากอเมริกาที่เรามัน
199  US ดอลลาร์ประมาณนั้น
6,000 บาทน่ะก็แพงมากหรอกแต่พอซื้อ
โทรศัพท์ไอโฟนแล้วมันใช้ Apple  ID ใช้
อีเมล์เดียวกันน่ะแล้วมันจะเช็คได้เชื่อ
ไหมว่า find  my  phone ให้
กูเกลียดมันติดๆอยู่ที่ออฟฟิศอะ
เหมือนแบบมันจะมีโลเคชั่นน่ะค่ะว่า iPod
ของเราอยู่ที่ไหนมันก็จิต If  you  are
real ในออฟฟิศเราอ่ะเราก็แค่ยอมไป
นั่นแหละเคยลืม 1 ครั้งชายค่ะลืม i  i
และท็อดด์
iPad เนาะที่ไว้ฟังเพลงฟังเพลงทรายน่า
รักอ่ะรู้สึกแบบคิดว่าครูหญิงเองขี้ลืม
ใช่ไหม
ตายค่ะเป็นคนขี้ลืมมากๆถ้ากู้หญิงมี
กระเป๋าอย่างเงี้ยกระเป๋าเวลาไปข้างนอก
บ้านคือของทุกช้างอ่ะไอ้ไปนามบัตร
เอทีเอ็มหรือว่าไอดีการ์ดใหม่บัตรประชาชน
หรือกระเป๋าเงินเนี่ยกูยิ่งต้องใส่ผู้
หญิงมั้ยเปลี่ยนกระเป๋านะคะครูเรียม
ไซส์กระเป๋าเนี้ย 1 ใบไม่ค่อยเปลี่ยนไม่
เปลี่ยนระเป๋าทุกวันครูเรียมเปลี่ยน
กระเป๋าทุกวันไหมไม่ค่ะไม่เปลี่ยนกระเป๋า
ทุกวันเพราะคิดว่าเวลาจะออกไปนอกบ้าน
เลี้ยงก็หยิบกระเป๋าใบนี้แล้วก็ออกไปเลย
ใช่ผู้หญิงเคยหรือยังอ่ะผู้หญิงที่ว่าถ้า
กูหญิง
พี่แจใส่เอากระเป๋าตังค์ใส่เอาโทรศัพท์
ใส่กระเป๋าแล้วก็แบบลืมลืมกระเป๋าหรือ
เปล่า
คุณของเคยเหรอคะวิ่งเลยเคยหาผู้หญิงเรา
คิดมากกว่านั้นอ่ะเมื่อก่อนอ่ะเมื่อก่อน
นะเดี๋ยวไม่มีกระเป๋าแบบนี้นะเตรียมก็จะ
ถือโทรศัพท์
ถือกระเป๋าตังค์
กุญแจรถเนี้ยเราก็ถือแบบนี้แล้วก็เดิน
เดินเดินๆ
ซื้อของ
แล้วเวลาซื้อของน่ะเราจะได้ถูกมาเป็นถุง
พลาสติกแบบนี้ใช่ไหมคะค่ะจะพลาสติกประมาณ
นี้
ก็กินหยิบของในถุงมากินกินหมดก็เอาเนี่ย
กับจะเอาตังค์
กุญแจโทรศัพท์ใส่ในถุงแต่งมีถึงเนี่ย
หิวเดินเล่นเดินเล่นเดินเล่นไปเข้าเล่น
เตอร์ถังขยะค่ะ
รู้ไหมจะบอกเนี่ยผู้หญิงยังเจอแบบถังขยะ
ข้างๆทาง
เลี้ยงทาง
โยนลงถังขยะทิ้งถุงพลาสติกใช่ทิ้งถุง
พลาสติกน่ะแต่ว่าขยะ
ๆแล้วยกเรียนว่ากลับบ้านขับรถเอาวันนั้น
กลับบ้านเลยนั่งรถเมล์ C
ค่ะอ่า
อุ้ยดีมากๆเลยมึงฟรี
นั่งรถเมล์ปีนะคะวันนึง
กรุงเทพฯมันจะมีรถเมล์ฟรี
ก็ไม่ต้องก็ไม่ต้องใช้เงินใช่มั้ยก็ไม่
ต้องหยิบกระเป๋าขึ้นมาให้
เนี่ยก็ขึ้นขึ้นรถเมล์ไป
แล้วไม่ต้องหยิบกระเป๋าเพราะว่าฟรีไม่
ต้องจ่ายเงิน
ก็นั่งสบายสบายๆกลับไปถึงที่ห้อง
จะเปิดห้องเปิดห้องไม่ได้ไม่มีกุญแจก็เลย
[เพลง]
ถูกจะได้
ในถุงคิดทิ้งถังขยะไปเรียบร้อยแล้วค่ะ
ผู้หญิงคิดว่าเขาหรือไหม
กล้วยอ่ะ
อย่าลืมบอกผู้หญิงน่ะ
แล้วมันจะผู้หญิงก็เคยแบบโหลด 1
osawa ไม่ได้คือเรียนกลับไปเอาไหมหรอไม่
เอาแต่ว่าไม่ได้แล้วมีคนเอาจากถังขยะไป
เจอแล้วใช่ตอนแรกเตรียมคิดคิดว่าถ้าเกิด
โทรโทรศัพท์จะมีคนน่ะได้ยินเสียงโทรศัพท์
แต่ก็มีคนได้ยินเสียงโทรศัพท์แหละแต่เขา
ก็เก็บแต่งกระเป๋ากลับบ้านเขาไปเลยเตรียม
มาไม่ได้ไม่ได้กุญแจไม่ได้กระเป๋าเงินไม่
ได้โทรศัพท์
ใช่เพราะว่าขี้ดีมีเงินเยอะไหมคะใน
กระเป๋า
คิดว่าไม่เยอะนะคะมีเงินมีเงินอ่ะ
[เพลง]
ที่ขี้ลืมใช่มั้ยก็คือแบบลืมง่ายๆลืมแบบ
บ่อยๆขึ้นคู่หญิงคิดว่าที่ผู้หญิงเคยลืม
แล้วรู้สึกแบบ
คล้ายๆกับครูเรียมคือไม่ใช่ iPod นะก็คือ
เคยลืมปิดแอร์
ก็คือออกจากช่องก็คือแอร์เนี่ยเปิดตั้ง
แต่สมมติประมาณ 20:00 นเมื่อคืนเมื่อคืน
20:00 นก็เปิดแล้วก็พอตอนเช้าตื่นนอนก็
อาบน้ำแต่งตัวออกจากบ้าน
ลืมปิดแอร์เพราะว่าทุกครั้งเนี่ยตื่นนอน
มาจะปิดแอร์เลยแต่วันนี้เนี่ยตื่นนอนแล้ว
ก็รีบไปอาบน้ำ
แล้วก็คิดออกปิดแอร์แล้วแล้วก็รีบออกจาก
บ้านไปทำงานกลับแล้วพอเดินกลับมาจะถึง
ห้องใช่มั้ยแบบอุ้ยทำไมวันนี้ห้องมันเย็น
ๆเพียงไม่ได้เข้าไปนะแต่ประตูเนี่ยมันจะ
มีช่องอารมร์มันออกแล้วก็ทำไมวันนี้ห้อง
มันเย็นๆ
ปิดแอร์หรอแล้วก็เปิดเข้าไปก็แบบโหห้อง
ขึ้นหนาเอาว่าผู้หญิงเปิดแอร์ไว้ 24
ชั่วโมงแล้วนักเรียนรูถ้าเกิดครูหินลืม
ปิดแอร์ผู้หญิงจะต้องจ่ายค่าไฟประมาณเท่า
ไหร่คะเนี่ย
งูฆ่าใครก็แพงนะเยอะๆค่ะเดือนนั้นก็เลย
คิดไอ้ข่าวไปเท่าไหร่นะคือปกติค่าไฟผู้
หญิงประมาณ 1,000 บาทประมาณนะนี้ประมาณพอ
ลืมปิดแอร์ 1 วันก็คิดว่าเดือนนั้นจำไม่
ได้อ่ะแต่ว่ามันอาจจะบวกบวกแล้วสัก 2  300
บาทก็คือแพงนะมันเป็นฤดูฝนไงฤดูฝนไม่ใช่
ฤดูร้อนนี้เอาล่ะค่ะงั้นหลังจากนั้นก็คือ
แบบก่อนออกจากบ้านคุยเช็คแอร์เท่านั้น
กลัวลืมปิดแอร์เรื่อยบางทีก็ลืมปิดนั่น
แหละเนาะ
ฉะนั้นสร้างสรรค์ก๊อกน้ำแบบเนี้ย
เปิดน้ำไว้
ทรายลืมปิดน้ำลืมอะไรนะปิดแบบรัฐใช่ไหม
ครับไฟแบบนี้ค่ะบางครั้งเราก็มีปลั๊กไฟ
ใช่ไหมปลั๊กไฟเงี้ยลืมปิดลืม
อุ้ยๆๆลืมถอดนะคะก็คนขี้ลืมก็ต้องเดิน
check  check  check  check  check
check เสร็จแล้วเดินออกมา
หรือยังนะเดินอีก 1 รอบ
ใช่
ก็ไม่รู้ว่านะอะไรนะคะเรียนคนขี้ลืมจะ
เป็นแบบนั้นเลย
มาถึงก็เป็นผู้เรียนก็เป็นชื่อปิ๊กผู้
หญิงเนี่ยลืมจะต้องเดิน 2 รอบทุกครั้ง
ทว่าคิดเราปิดหรือยังนะเนี่ยแหละไม่รู้
ว่านักเรียนน้องเป็นคนขี้ลืมเหมือนเราสอง
คนหรือเปล่า
ช่าก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้นะคะว่านักเรียน
ก็เคยลืมปิดแอร์หรือว่าเคยเอาเงินใส่ถุง
พลาสติกแล้วก็ลืมเราก็ทิ้งแบบคู่เรียม
หรือเปล่าอันนี้ขี้ลืมมากๆนะพี่มั้ยนี่
มั้ยพี่ใครทำแบบนี้ไหมเดี๋ยวลองคอมเมนต์
มาดูนะคะเลยนะถ้าเกิดให้เล่าในตอนนี้นะคะ
เรียงแบบมีลืมอีกหลายอย่างมากๆ
ชายแต่ว่าวันนี้มันหมดเวลาแล้วนะวีดีโอ
นี้นะคะค่ะเดี๋ยวก็เจอกันใหม่ในวีดีโอ
หน้าชายค่ะสำหรับขอลาไปก่อนแล้วค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะพี่ค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนไม่ไหว
สวัสดีค่ะไปงานตั้งแต่ไม่ลืมเรานะอ่า